what is this exactly sign up no idea
what we're doing right now
like what category is this under no no
just so I can be prepared I'm [ __ ] no
hey guys I'm Ryan Wright illicit be
crazy we're gonna watch some video
called die fantasy honestly I don't know
anything about it no clue I don't know
what we're about to watch it's mystery I
thought it was a video game and
apparently it's not know Inc it's just
gonna be surprised me honestly this is
the first time I'm a been hearing about
it mmm mmm oh
oh I feel amazing really get you oh okay
okay
oh sweet all right
I'm really liking this video so far but
you are
music
peer pressure
you
Wow
now
you
so here I feel so bad I don't know how
to feel right now
what um this what's wrong with you
people
hi why you suggest me watch stuff like
this what I first I had to watch Shrek
right people but no we all had to do
thank you whoever suggested that me
watch don't hug me I'm scared and now
I'm watching this I I'm having
nightmares forever no seriously like who
thinks something who ok first who thinks
about it second and who actually follows
through with animates it what who are
you
I kind of want to know your life but the
same time I don't feel like I should
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe
melissa has a channel too
I do I do and it won't have that on it
but it's called Alyssa be crazy that
this is crazy what is that I don't want
to feel right now I just Kristen
Ellington you know I make me like out of
touch a reality for a little bit I think
we need a dose of friends in our life
right now what's really weird about that
video is the music's really good I know
and so I was enjoying what I was
watching and that's what makes me feel
really disturbed was that I enjoyed that
so now I'm questioning myself it's like
the first time I saw a double badge
I'm a little proud of myself I don't
know what that is right now that's when
two penises are on one vagina oh I
didn't know how to feel about two
penises touching each other well inside
of a vagina the first time I saw it but
I enjoyed it and I was really
questioning my life at that point
listen let's do some shout outs Multi
Randy 49 please shout out okay hi
hey multi Randy 49 um you're probably in
a better state of mind uh you're
probably one of those [ __ ] who wanted
me to watch this how do you requested
you actually get for this Oh multiple
requests yeah
multi Randy 49 you should change your
name to multi Randy 69 haha
mihi claudio calling all rejects I want
to shout out please and thank you ii yo
ii you spelled you wrong i think we can
hang with you I this is where I picked
make fun other grammar because they
spelled it like that this fella wrong
we like you yeah he always funny yeah me
Claudio you're uh I'm sorry I'm still
reflecting on this I my brain I saw it's
like stuck in my head you know it's like
stuck in my head like that's the worst
part it's like I want to remember the
song but it's like association now it's
like I like it but I don't want to see
it it's like I hear the song I like the
song and as the images are playing in my
mind and it's it was good animation me
Claudio um ah
you totally have a shout out you look
hot in your photo this is where I hit on
you know like 12 it doesn't matter at
this point okay you're if you're 12 yo
you'll be a very pretty girl one day I
mean
what does it matter me Claudia does any
of this really matter what is life does
do we need to live me oh wait do you
know why are we here can you just leave
a comment and tell us what you think you
should live thanks Cobra
gladiator hey how you doing recently
subbed and I don't get a lot of
attention and while I'm not a [ __ ] for
it I wouldn't mind some so would you
mind giving me a shout out PS has anyone
ever told you Ryan that you look less
high he always jokes about him being
high Paul F Tompkins with more hair well
I think you do either way good content
dude keep at it I look less high now
that's a good compliment it's probably
cuz I use eye drops he goes through
those like cupcakes I use about a full
bottle of eye drops everyday sorry I
don't have a joke for you I I just
honestly answered that for you I
coke cobra gladiator I'm so glad you
subbed I'm sorry you don't get a lot of
attention does anyone really need
attention anymore this attention matter
attention why do we crave attention from
other people's lists for reason I don't
like attention you know people like us
on the Internet I like you guys got my
attention and then got this video to my
attention so what does attention really
get you nightmares
attention just leads down darker paths
don't seek attention so just be you I
love you find you when you don't look or
actively search bizarre things in the
keywords on YouTube and then you want
other people to be disturbed because you
want them to you know you don't want to
feel so lonely so you bring people down
to their level to your level
she looked empty like hollowed out no
Ryan I mean Ryan your name's not Ryan my
name's Ryan my name's Ryan um I I do
like less hi and um I don't know who
Paul F Tompkins is I don't have no idea
I'm afraid to look it up because I'm
afraid it's something disturbing so I
think we just need to stay off the
internet for like 24 hours and just not
know like a couple hours that's better
right
Internet you love you that is what you
create internet Oh
that is what we don't need in our lives
right now